white privilege with ABS Justin Bieber
is just broken a record and sadly that
record is not believed by Justin Bieber
instead he's broken the record
previously held by the Beatles for
having two top three billboard songs for
the most consecutive league she consists
cover right uh it is formal where that
is yeah yeah he's going to a wedding
there the old record was twelve weeks
with the Biebs up to the thirteen which
also happens to be the age of most of
his fans the remaining Beatles took the
news pretty hard when they heard about
Bieber's accomplishment they said quote
whoo but since this kid can do anything
now except girl mustache comedians
what's another record Justin Bieber is
going to break Holly where I'll stop
this hand yes why you just want to get
lost in them I'm going to roll around in
a Mike Lawrence both go bold cautionary
tale hahaha
good Marcela heading off the most
amber rollers
[Music]
[Applause]